hey everybody and welcome to a magical
wild ride with sto I know that magical
is pretty on the nose for this one but I
mean what other magician are we going to
get certainly not David Blaine after he
hears what Chris Angel has to say about
him on this episode ha and uh speaking
of this episode it's not just juicy
because of that we get into a lot of
crazy stuff and and Chris Angel goes in
on psychics but he's actually pretty
open-minded about uh the afterlife so
yeah we're we're really uh getting deep
on this one and I want you guys to know
that I feel like I'm in a pretty good
place uh candidly I was struggling for
the last couple of months uh you know I
was just really letting uh negative
comments bum me out I kind of got
withdrawn um but I'm bouncing back and
um here we are and this is a a wild
episode and I'll talk to you at the end
of it too so let's get into
it ladies and Gentlemen people of the
Universe I bring to you Chris Angel
what's up yeah how are you my brother
good to see you good to see you in my
parking lot here at Chris Angel Studios
we have the van of Vans this is the way
to do it you're like CNN dude you're
like Fox you're like all of these
Networks
that have a rolling truck that go to the
guest and get them on it and people
think they're like in a studio so we're
in the van studio right now we are uh I
want to show you a
photo of oh no you me Tom Green Carrot
Top and flavor
flave drop it to Isaac yeah it's uh I
don't know how what a mly crew huh I I
have no idea how I didn't give that to
Isaac ahead of time this photo um it it
uh invited the most harsh and hateful
comments
on people love the
group love hated never ignored where was
this why was this how was this this was
in
2013 at uh some big nightclub I think
that was at the win if I'm correct I
used to go there all the time
yeah I mean dude and and uh you're the
last one of this group to uh to make it
onto the podcast we've had Flav Flav
Carrot Top Tom Green well I I I'm
honored I don't know if you saved the
best for last but I'm honored to be on
tell you man Carrot Top crushed it on
here dude what a great guy he is yeah
I'm trying to get him on my podcast but
he's very elusive oh very
elusive well um Carrot Top Scotty what's
up is he considered a m magician no he's
a comedian he's a comedian yeah he he
makes more money than most of the
Comedians and he does people are like oh
he's not a comedian cuz he does props
but the dude is really insanely talented
I've known him forever his show is
hilarious yeah you saw his show last
time you were out yeah yeah I went to
and I absolutely loved it he's
criminally underrated car yeah he's he's
awesome I call him KT
nice nice um so we ended up that night
like going out somewhere after that even
I I think it was that night yeah I I I
don't I don't that whole part of my life
was kind of a blur okay kind of a blur I
don't I don't really remember I used to
come home at like 7:8 in the morning
like every night um that's when you know
when you move to Vegas and you have a
little bit of success you're just like
you're out every night and
um you you run we we didn't plan it we
just ran into each other I think Tom
Green came I think it was me and Tom
Green maybe katop but then we just like
Flav is everywhere now like you just run
into him and he's one of my he's been to
my show like 50 times yeah I love him
too I love all these guys he lives out
in Vegas now right yeah yeah he's he's
been in Vegas for some time and he's
been my brother he he comes to my house
on Fourth of July and he brings like
$110,000 worth of fireworks and I live
in like a in an area that like has like
four houses in a gated community and he
like it looks like a third world country
when he's done there is like paper and
fires and I'm like worried like we're
going to get like you know get arrested
um something that you have no experience
in right but uh but yeah these these
were the times you know like this was
exciting you know this was craziness and
um you know now I have three kids I
chill and since then huh so yeah I've
been busy wow I'm old I'm 56 dude I have
three I have a
2-year-old man that's crazy so we hung
out that night for the first time and
and and we and we settled something I
didn't even remember that I'd said
anything at a public level but I I had
effectively attacked you there was a me
yeah how did you attack me it was and
physically no no no I remember you you
called me out about it too what it was
was you had a a huge rad stunt that you
did where like you were suspended with
hooks going through your back I remember
that well and somebody asked me about it
or something and I was like ah like it
like the hooks through the back I I
don't think it's really funny or
something oh definitely wasn't funny it
was [__] painful yeah I like I would
have I was I was like maybe I would have
done uh I I would have done it with
hooks through my butt cheeks or
something I don't know well you're
crazier than me yeah you know I'm I'm
I'm in the world of Illusion even though
I Had No Illusion I had no painkillers
no numbers and I I I hung for six hours
I broke the record yeah and you're
you're not trying to get the humor out
of it I was ever the first person ever
hang from a helicopter I didn't realize
that the helicopter with the camera was
going to create turbulence and it was
excruciatingly painful I was up there
for 30 something minutes but no I didn't
do it as like a jackass thing right
right right you know I did it as like
you know Mind Over Matter kind of thing
to try to inspire people that you know
are trying to accomplish things that
look impossible trying to show you that
anything is possible yeah and and dude
I'm I'm I'm thrilled that you don't even
remember that no good steo who no I'm
just
kid how long does it take to prep for
something like that the helicopter one
um well I produced the show and uh and
so it was when I first went up I felt
like I was going to puke so they had to
bring me down and the guy that does the
Pearson Alan Faulkner I think his name
was nice guy said once you come down
you're never going to go back up and I I
I was like the money is on the line with
me because if I don't do it I lose all
this money that I now have to create
content that I've already spent for
helicopters this location so I had to
produce it didn't matter what I thought
and it was very difficult to get back up
but I uh I did and I was up there for
like 35 minutes flying around with four
Fish Hooks through my back the first
person to ever do this and then prior to
this I hung for six hours in Time Square
and you know you've seen all things in
Time Square but when you see a dude
hanging for 6 hours in the middle of
Broadway in 43rd people like like
looking at me and like in a puke because
the skin the stretches but yeah steo if
you would have if you would have done
this you would have done it like
you know and some crazy I I don't know
if you could physically do that you'd
rip your ball your balls right off
because because if you if if the hook
goes in too shallow it rips out of your
skin if it goes in too deep it could do
muscle damage so it's really it's really
dangerous at that point in my life I was
doing [__] I spent 24 hours on the water
I did a lot of [__] that like I would
never do today you know kids and
everything but I was so desperate to to
achieve what I had in my head that I
didn't give a [__] what the consequences
were like I said either I'm going to get
out of this condition physically you
know on my own terms or you're going to
pull me out in the body bag there was no
like there was no way I was going to
lose I was going to die trying that's
how bad I wanted to succeed in my life I
I just I just was willing to die from my
art why were you ready to throw up on
there because of the pain or because of
the it was it you know when you're skin
separates from your muscle and you're
hanging basically like you know when you
pick up a cat by the neck that's kind of
how you're hanging you're hanging from
your skin all of the weight of
everything internally is just like
stretched and uh it it's just insanely
painful I only had one other thing that
was more painful than that and that was
believe it or not I I shot something and
I had to put Prosthetics on my face and
when the guy removed the Prosthetics
either the the the liquid that he was
using to remove the glue or something
got into my air eard drum and I wanted
to take a gun and blow my brains out the
pain was I couldn't it just was just
nonstop pain it was the craziest pain I
ever had worse than anything I ever
experienced and that was second but you
you have done things and I'm going to
ask you this do my podcast but the
things that you have done you know
without really a lot of planning like
you've done a lot of things like just
I'm going to do this and just had
something to drink and Bam literally did
the craziest things that literally could
have killed yourself and you've ended up
in a hospital so many times like what
was the mental state to do that and how
did you prepare or you didn't prepare
like I just said just did it
um yeah the uh the the the mental state
I think that my my general position is
that my need for attention outweighs my
need for safety and comfort so you
willing to die for your for your for
your performance art yeah pretty much we
have that in common I mean that's the
the hard part is like cuz because
there's no planning with Steve it's all
like spontaneous or as close as you can
get so me having the plan like help call
the places and get it approved like I
think I think it'd be a lot easier if we
had like a three days to prep but like
sometimes we have like four hours yeah
you you you have to I did like over a
thousand demonstrations just on mind
freak and I had to do 28 episodes in one
season so that would be you know 10 to
15 demonstrations that I had to have
prepared and the sheer volume of doing
that you just don't have that time and
you don't have that budget so it it's
like you know you just you you take
chances I took a shitload of chances I I
was on Planet Hollywood 30 m hour winds
trying to walk down at 550 feet in the
air with no safety like it was the
craziest thing like I have video of this
and my brother freaking out because he
thinks I'm going to get blown over then
the cops come because I wasn't known at
that time and people thought like I was
a
jumper but so how long are you how long
does it take you to prep for something
like that well then no time if I'm doing
something now I have a team you know I
these Studios these are my buildings so
I we fabricate everything we do
everything engineering you know we we we
do everything in house so it becomes um
it's a very different Dynamic than when
you're doing it in your garage you know
and you have two people doing it with
you he said when you move to Las Vegas
and you have some kind of success that
you're out all the time and it's good
like you had more than a little bit of
success let me ask you why should Chris
Angel be the one with more than just a
little bit of success why shouldn't you
have tons of success when it's so doable
to grow an audience online and sell
products to them these days and if
you're shipping your own products to
your own customers then the way to do
that is with ship station like that's
how you get successful Johnny Knoxville
and steo skateboard 2.0 out to the
people when the bucket list DVDs are
signed and Shrink wrapped and ready to
go I mean come on ship station is the
way to do it it takes all of your
different shippers all of your different
platforms and just combines them into
one easy to use interface with the best
rates for shipping and it just you know
you get your order
print out the label slap it on the box
put the product in it's out the door and
you're on your way to having more than
just a little bit of success and we've
got a great deal for the listeners of
the Wild Ride podcast if you go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
steo you get a risk-free 30-day trial so
that you can find out just how much
potential there is so to get your risk
free 30-day free trial go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
steo it's time to have success let's
make ship happen and let's get back to
it right I mean it it uh when you can't
how much different was getting the
residency with the the the Believe show
well the Believe show was a [__] show um
that was produced and owned by cus and I
was basically their puppet and I it was
the best experience of my life and it
was the worst experience of my life I
learned so much from it my show a Planet
Hollywood Mind Freak right now is the
most
insane show and I would love for you all
to come see it it it has a tornado in it
it's it's like physically the people are
immersed in it and I'm flying around you
see me on the ladder there just doing
the craziest [__] with people in the
audience I just do it's just a crazy
show you'll cry you'll be scared you'll
you you you'll be like energized it's
it's just a Nutty show and it's um it's
evolved and transformed into the number
one uh residency Show in Las Vegas which
is insane we bring in like you know a
$150 million into the casino a year
there's been stories written about it
and uh lot a lot of lot of people that
hate me for it and a lot of people that
love me for it but um at the end of the
day having the live show is awesome i'
I've done over 5,000 shows in Vegas I've
been performing here since 2008 2005
with mind freak but television is a
completely different Beast than live you
know that you're doing comedy you're
like killing it you're out there touring
you're doing all that you know and then
you do a movie like jackass or you do
like you know MTV jackass each medium
has its own things that you love about
it and things that you're not as much of
a fan about right so it's all different
you just got to play in that medium and
and know how to engage the audience or
the viewer you know but do you love
doing a residency versus like doing a
world tour it's a job you know it's it's
when you when you go out and you tour
it's a very different experience yeah I
I had the opportunity one time to have
uh I think it was a dinner with Elton
John and and he said you know Las Vegas
audiences are so jaded it's the it's the
toughest audience because they're coming
in they're seeing you then they're doing
this then they're seeing that person
then they're going out to a club lots of
things to do but when you tour it's an
event you know the radio's talking about
it you know people are driving six hours
to see steo you know it's an event it's
a different type of energy because
they're not going to do this this this
they're they're planning this for months
that they're coming to see you so
they're hyped up they're getting them
themselves more hyped up and so um it's
just a it's just a very different um uh
Dynamic um but but for me now doing it
in Vegas for so long listen I'm blessed
I have an incredible life but it's a job
it's not something that I um you know
always look forward to do I'm being
honest with you it's it's sometimes you
know I'm not feeling good I [__] up my
ankle um you know and I have to go do
the show and I've never missed a show
since I've been in Vegas I've done every
show because when I came to Vegas when I
had nothing I remember I had a I
couldn't even afford to rent a car and I
walked to go see the show that I bought
tickets for and it was cancelled I was
so pissed I spent the money on the plane
ticket on the
hotel who is the show I I don't want to
say God Rest their soul um but uh all I
can say is this is that I just promised
myself that if I was ever blessed and
fortunate enough to have success that I
would never cancel so I do the shows
when I'm on stage I love doing it when I
tour it's an excitement about that you
know you wake up you're doing one
nighters I wake up you know I'm in a
different place the crew set up my [__]
in like three or four hours I go out I
do the show you know go maybe play a
little Blackjack have some fun jump back
on a bus do the same thing the next day
all over again so it's different things
you know um but I'm blessed to do what I
do uh Planet Hollywood is a great home
mind freak is a great show and um I'll
be doing it tomorrow night through
Sunday and I continuously do that about
200 times a year I used to do it 460
shows a year now I'm down about 200 plus
all these other projects so it's good
it's it's it's a good time but uh buy
when you do it on tour how many trucks
does it take I keep it simple I do
another show it's called raw which I
played on Broadway and I tour with it I
do 153t truck three tour buses that's it
we set up in less than 4 hours and we
tear down in about 45 minutes but but
you know if you're a comedian how how
big of a truck do you need for your
microphone right or a ladder you bring a
ladder right cuz I saw you um when you
were working um here in Vegas I'm trying
to think I think Tom Green and you were
awesome like that's when you were like
really starting to really like focus on
Comedy right yeah that was that was very
green at that time that why you were
here in that in that
photo was it no no no no no that photo
that that yeah Tom Green and I were
doing the the show together yeah okay so
2013 2013 wow now now your [__] is like
crazy man like you're selling out venues
all over the place your your Instagram
your your posts blow up and uh yeah it's
it's incredible because you don't see
that necessarily from the same um folks
that you know that were featured in
right in the movie so you've been you
worked hard to get there I've definitely
put put the work in um it
uh it's it's been it's been a wild a
wild wild thing um you reached out um
about the this magic show with the Stars
and I wasn't able to do that because I
was on tour right but uh how did that go
it went great but the amount of work it
was for me um as the executive producer
and uh Creator it it it just was
overwhelming and um
it just um it the artists that I brought
on you know Frank M Randy competing
against each other or Donnie Osman and
Debbie Gibson or you know miles Brown
and uh you know just a host of really
cool people um it was it was a great
show it was fun but one season for me
was was enough yeah and and where did
that live on the CW yeah yeah CW but
they were going through some changes
they uh went through a new president the
new marketing department so I was in
it in their Valley let's just say when
we were uh talking to Carrot Top um he
what what was it the he had a an
encounter with George Carlin George car
was like his his uh his his mentor like
not Mentor but it was like like his uh
role model that clip has like four or
five million views on on YouTube crazy
talking about George Carlin it went
super viral which which makes me want to
ask you do you have like in the the the
world of Illusion somebody who was like
a hero to you yeah I I you know I never
was a big fan of magicians because I
always thought they were so hokey
honestly um there were obviously you
know like Doug Henning that was a
product of his times you know you had
Sig freed and Roy um but a guy named
Rich yardi uh from Lima Peru really
really inspired me because he just like
he didn't have the flash he just used
simple objects a broom a a chair and and
he would create Miracles and he had such
a commanding presence he passed away in
the 80s but uh he had a real effect on
me so did Houdini
obviously um but he did crazy things he
like cut a girl he like ripped a girl in
half with a chainsaw the buzzsaw right
there and he didn't put her back
together he left her bleeding and he
would have excuse me the audience come
up and look at this his daughter
actually just sitting there like look
appearing like she's dead just like a
massacre took place and I was just like
wow that is not like the family magic
show that we we expect to see and I love
the fact that he did something so
unorthodox and so provocative and I
think that had a lasting he did things
with razor blades which I do on my show
he you you I think you did the razor
blades didn't you do the didn't you do
the razor blad did you do something ra
he choose glass oh yeah glass yeah okay
so razor blades glass um but yeah so uh
uh he he was really really cool and uh I
I have a little piece that I pay tribute
to him in my show currently which is
called the the cult the chair but my
interpretation of it is there anybody
that like cuz your name's synonymous
with Vega like you know I'm not trying
to suck your dick or anything but like
you're you're a big deal in Vegas is
there anybody that like that like you
get Star Struck over like this [__]
guy's at my show like what the [__]
Wayne Newton is he still doing shows
he's been to my show yeah he he's he's
still doing shows for Caesars um I don't
know if he's located at Caesars but the
Caesar's company he's uh uh lovely guy
to me very very uh obviously you know he
is Mr Las Vegas and you know you got
Tony Orlando who's doing the podcast for
me today who's like my father who is a a
legend has the greatest stories about
you know the Rat Pack and just like old
Vegas and stuff you know Tony orando is
like uh I've learned so much from him
you know the guy is still performing and
and kicking ass and he's dear friends he
comes over he was just over for
Christmas um but um yeah there there are
like you know people that you know I I
enjoy I like to see any show I don't
care if it's a shitty show if it's an
okay show or it's a great show you can
learn from anything um and I love seeing
things and and trying to take away you
know something from that experience
because um you know there's it could
always be better right you do a show you
always can there's always something you
like the timing of that or the way I
deliver that or maybe I have to edit
that can it's like it's like in it's not
tangible it's like trying to hold water
you know art is is to have Perfection is
like impossible
so to see other people it helps you kind
of gauge like okay that's what I
shouldn't do that's what I should do not
to try to copy it but just the spirit of
what they're doing yeah what about other
uh popular mag magicians or illusionists
like let's just say David Blaine do you
have relationships with those guys like
do you ever like do you collab do you
beef or anything like that like what's
like it's about to go down and knowing
what Chris Angel is about to share with
us I got to say my heart rate is feeling
a little bit elevated but I can tell you
exactly how elevated because I wear
whoop band and it's got a waterproof
charger so you never got to take it off
and it tells me everything like my how
my heart rate's doing my heart rate
variability how I slept like how much
time in each different stage of sleep RM
is the one that you want how many
calories I burned what activities I'm
doing and it really is the way to stay
on top of your health it's called whoop
wh o p the website is whoop.com
wh.com and it is the most sophisticated
Fitness tracking device known to man I
love it I've been wearing it for years
now and dude I just can't say enough
good things about it and if you want to
get one the actual whoop band and the
waterproof charger is completely free
what you pay for is the membership to
have the app tell you everything about
what's going on with your body and you
can get 10% off that membership if you
go to whoop.com and use the promo code
steo again it's the best fitness
tracking device there is and you should
try it by going to whoop.com and using
the promo code steo and let's get back
to
it I don't know how's your relationships
going
all right I'm going to tell you a story
that I have not told anyone wow all
right so listen David Blaine I get props
to he came out did street magic you know
blew up before I did and give him all
the props in the world um when he was
when he was coming up you know I I was
very aggressive um because I had a dream
I had a vision in my mind I wanted to
accomplish
it so you know I would say look whatever
David is doing I can do it and I'll do
it side by side with him and I guarantee
you that whatever he does I'll last
longer I'll do it better I'll do
whatever because I was committed to give
my life to beating him or anyone else
because I had something so bad that I
wanted and he had it so he had a big
taret Target on his head and so um you
know I uh since then recently last year
went to go see his show and um you know
it's nothing personal it was just like
people do it to me all the time and it's
like bring it it's it's totally like
part of the thing because in the magic
world it's you know if you go up to
somebody on the street and you say name
five magicians they have a difficult
time doing that it's very it's a very
small place at the top yeah and
especially you know what what I'm doing
with live and television and stuff so
anyway I saw him and I I I uh went to
his show and I was like dude you know I
just want to wipe this leg clean I
haven't I've never met you before so I
just want to say like you know no hard
feelings like I I apologize for anything
that might have offended you or anything
like that and um I took off I had a
beautiful beautiful ring gorgeous ring
like 20 G's I took it off and I said
this is for for you and I said let's
let's you know build a friendship and
stuff like that because I'm talking this
was in like in in like the early what
2000s that this went down it's like so
many years ago and I gave it to him and
uh and he's like oh I don't I can't
accept this because I'm a minimalist and
and then he called this friend over like
hey let's put it in a
museum you know like you could do
whatever you want that I'm giving it to
you and then the guy in he's like oh
okay thank you I like well I gave it to
David if he wants to give it to you
that's his business because it's a gift
from
me and then I was like hey let's do a
picture and he's like oh I can't do a
picture with just you and me alone
and it's just [__] bizarre dude like
just bizarre behavior and it's like dude
grow up like is weird it's it's it's
like you know we're both adults we both
have children I had a kid with cancer
like you know it wasn't like we had a
fist fight it's not like we ever even
met before it's not like we ever even
had a conversation on the phone nothing
it was just some banter in the in the
Press because I because I wanted to
succeed and you know he's ripped me off
with stuff that I've done you know like
I've been under the water for 24 hours
then he borrowed that and then he did it
later which is totally cool like God
bless him like it's not a big deal do
your thing man it's all good but life is
too short to sit here and and uh but you
know the truth is is that I'm out there
um doing my thing pretty successful at
doing it and uh I never look behind me
wow that's up yes so you guys aren't
having dinner together all the mag no I
I I I text him after it like you think
he would say hey Chris thanks for the
you know the ring or whatever I texted
him and I was like hey man happy
Father's Day thanks for having us at the
the show whatever and uh never responded
so I was like cool dude like it's all
good like I wish wish him and everyone
else the best yeah life is too short man
and when you have a kid with cancer and
you realize how fragile life is all this
other [__] like you never see a hearse
pulling a U-Haul it means nothing yeah
means nothing especially like you know
when you want to put love light and
positivity in the world right yeah I I
read about your kid having leukemia yeah
and going through John Christopher yeah
a thousand treatments well he went
through
1,95 days then he went to remission
which is three years he went into
remission for less than a year he got
a it basically uh came back I found it
in his testicles when he came out of the
shower I was like look that I was like
this doesn't look normal let's go to it
and then he went through another two
years of treatment so he was in it for
over six years and now my whole mission
in life and the reason why I believe I
was blessed was for the betterment of
children like I raise millions of
dollars for kids every scent that I
raise 100% of every scent I raise goes
to um these kids um cure for the kids
here in Las Vegas is a treatment center
that treated Johnny and other kids even
if they don't have insurance um make a
wish of Southern Nevada you know I uh uh
does a lot of really good things to give
kids the incentive to get through
treatment look forward for mentally to
do and so you know my whole mission in
life is to earmark that money make sure
it doesn't go to like expenses overhead
I pay all of that out of my pocket we
just raised I I think on December um
what was it the 18th um day before my
birthday I had a big event I had a bunch
of bands that you would love that just
play Cheap Trick and nice and um fast a
pussycat Ellie gun Skid Row uh uh bunch
of bands anyway they um we raised uh
about a million over a million six and
it all goes to kids and I raise money
every show so that's my mission in life
you know that's that's that's that's
what I'm here to try to do and I'm so
blessed that my kid is doing good he's
in school and uh you know it's just but
you never know man it's it's fragile
it's scary I mean leukemia is just kind
of like hit or miss there's no causes
for it one child every 2 minutes is
diagnosed with um pediatric cancer Jes
and um you know that's that's a huge
number one child every two minutes so um
you know not to bring the show down but
if people want to help they can go to
chrisangel.com they can watch a
documentary I made it's 13 minutes long
it's called
1095 and it's basically about 13 minutes
long took six years to make about what
we went through and people can donate a
dollar or watch here it is right here
yeah so um that's the documentary right
there people can watch that and that
share it and if they feel compelled
donate a dollar if they don't just share
it and uh hopefully we can raise
awareness and money and make pediatric
cancer disappear because it's uh when
you see kids and I go to hospitals and I
see these kids uh it um it really puts
everything in perspective you know
really puts everything in perspective
cuz they're so [__] innocent they
should be worrying about playing with
their toy yeah not like I I have to sit
there and get chemo for how many hours
or do a blood transfusion or do a SP fin
tap or you know all the [__] my my son
was hooked up to blandet Tuma maab uh
basically you know a machine 28 days a
month every other month it was I tried
to do it he lost all of his hair that's
him in the in the bed obviously uh there
and uh it's a it's a difficult situation
so for me that puts everything into
perspective and everything else you know
is um a blessing every moment is a gift
that's why you have to live your life
doing what you want to do put love light
and positivity out there don't do
something you hate to do for a living
try to do something life is too short
you know anyway yeah Scott and I are
obsessed with videos where people are
sharing their account of near-death
experiences where they've had the
experience of dying and going to the
other side and having what's called a
Life review and these accounts of Life
review are just incredibly consist
and um they these people talk about like
experiencing their whole life from the
perspective of everybody on whom they
had an impact so if you bummed somebody
out you experience it as that person
Plus without the limitations of time
like just infinite detail and infinite
like immersed in in in just Infinity of
that experience and um it it really
really makes us believe strongly that at
the end of the day the only thing that
matters is how you treated others 100%
it's you you
you as you get older I can tell you
reflect a lot and you think about how
fragile life is because you could my dad
died when he was 60 I'm 56 years old
like that's four years that's four more
Christmases that's four more birthdays
like you just put things in perspective
very very differently and
um yeah you got to you gotta you got to
like not sweat all the [__] right
and like you know that's why like when
you sit there and and said to me like oh
blah blah blah you want me to hold on to
that like oh dude you like what the [__]
like I'm G to hold on to that that's
what I'm saying like I forgive you like
I don't even have to say that like [__]
like you were doing what you were doing
you were in a specific spe place at that
time your career was in a specific spot
you might have been not clearheaded or
maybe you were and and and you say [__]
or you because we all evolve and
transform as people you there's never
it's never too late to change who you
are you never have to be that person you
the past is the past for a reason this
moment and the next moment I can choose
to be how I want to be how I've learned
from my past
that's the key and that's why I'm sad
for David I'm sad for him because he
can't understand that or accept that
like this [__] that happened or what
small little like nothingness is
something you're still holding on to
like don't hold on to it because it just
makes you internally have that turmoil h
bad for sure and whatever it was that I
said about you like yeah what is it I
want to know you near me now now I can
grab
you Isaac uh Isaac was trying to bring
it up and there's clearly no evidence of
it online you said you said this like in
the news well now you can make up and
make it look like it wasn't that bad I
don't know but uh but but whatever you
said I should should grow my hair is I
think what you said whatever it was it
was uh you
know certainly it came from Fear like I
wanted to to prop myself up let me try
people put other people down to try to
like build themselves up somehow and um
that that's what it was regardless of of
uh what like uh drug or whatever I was I
was on I think I've come a long way
since then I have no desire to put
anybody down yeah no it's it's it's and
it's honestly it's I didn't even it's
not a big deal you know what so much
[__] said about me from you know Perez
Hilton you know back in the day you know
wrote so much stuff about me I mean and
now we're friends like you can't I'm
actually taking them out to dinner on on
Saturday like you can't hold on to [__]
like that you got to grow up yeah I I
take that back because I I've said so
many dispar ing things about people I
can't I I can't sit here and say I don't
don't have a desire to put anybody down
you can't sometimes you have an opinion
you know have an opinion and it's not
always a positive opinion um I love PR
Hilton too yeah he's he's you know he
was one of the the first to do it the
way he did it and he transformed yeah
you know because he's not like putting
cumen on people's pictures and doing
that [__] which he used to do I I was
one with the cumins on my
but you know he's he's uh he's you know
he has kids and he's um you know he's
evolved and transformed and how I'm
going to sit here and hold that against
him or he's going to sit there and hold
what I did to him against him against me
like it's just it's crazy it's just you
got to move on man life is too short and
for sure forgive and forget and and try
to be friends and try to put love out
there like it's all about love light and
positivity for me I mean that's just my
perspective amen my brother it is all
about love light and positivity I
couldn't agree more and you know what
does not jive with that is negative
embarrassing shameful habits you got to
get rid of it man and the best way to do
that is to trade in a bad habit and
replace it with a good habit and that is
what fume is all about fume it's a
diffusive device it just flavors air
there's no battery there's no chemicals
there's no nothing it's just a healthy
thing that I personally love so much I
keep it in my pocket at all
times it's that simple I mean you can
trade in the chemicals and and and the
craziness and the embarrassment with
flavored air and next thing you know
you're on your way to being done with
that filthy bad habit and if you want to
try this they got what's called The
Journey pack you go to
tri.com
steo and use the promo code steo that's
TR R YF
m.com steo and use the promo code steo
for 10% off your fume Journey pack why
is it called The Journey pack because
when you get it you begin your journey
to a happier healthier version of you so
that you can live your life in love
light and positivity that's right so one
more time go to trif nume.com
steo and use the promo code steo for 10%
off your journey pack now let's get back
to
it it's the only thing there is man it's
the only thing there is is Perez Hilton
in Vegas yeah he moved out here
everybody's making the pilgrimage to
Vegas especially from California because
of the taxes and the craziness that's
going on people come out here are you
buddies with Sebastian Bach I am I love
him dude yeah he's like dude dude he the
sickest we we we just we just had him in
here and he was on fire yeah oh yeah
he's like amped up yeah he's always he
just he just uh came and uh he has an
amazing voice and he just uh graced us
with uh some songs for the charity cuz I
have this like event you have to come
next year I'll invite you love yeah
please it's Monday December 17th I think
next sure 18th or whatever it is but uh
but yeah we have I have like eight bands
that play um uh Paul Stanley came out um
who's a dear friend and uh and uh uh
Mark uh um the owner of the Raiders Mark
Davis and um everybody was there uh even
little Stevie
VanZant um Paul Stanley you just had him
on on your podcast you showed me that
has your podcast been released um I
released a couple episodes now I'm
holding it because I'm I'm working on
something a little bit
more uh meaningful as far as uh
Distributing it um so we'll see what
happens yeah people say you know Paul is
we were just talking last night Paul
everybody says that we're related
because we look very similar I mean he
doesn't have a beard on and all that
stuff going on but uh he is like the
dude is so generous so amazing and I was
at the two last shows at Madison Square
Garden and they they were just it was
spectacular I feel like I've never heard
anything negative about Paul Stanley
great guy
literally has done so much for my son
for can for Pediatric cancer is at my
event every
year donating jumping up on stage um
it's just a a one of my dear dear
friends that I'm so I value that
relationship because kiss was a huge
inspir ation to me you know when I was a
kid and still is and you know I'm sure
you were I had a kiss lunchbox really in
like first grade it's probably worth
millions now yeah it's uh yeah they they
have the most like merchandise you can
imagine but uh I have a couple of them
in in in in the uh I think that that was
actually
it like I'm going to I'm going to go
ahead and say I think that was
specifically my lunchbox in first grade
that's pretty look at the [__] that they
endured right when they came out look at
the [__] that they endured from critics
you know just bashing them and bashing
them and bashing them and they
persevered and where are those critics
and you know they played they were
playing for 50 75,000 people it's just
insane how big of shows are you doing
now well when I tour I do probably 6,000
wow and then here it's about 1800 yeah
wow that adds up over 300 shows 200
shows a year that's crazy because I mean
Carrot Top his show is just like in such
a small intimate it's a great venue for
for his show but uh 1500 that that seems
intimidating to like it you know listen
Vegas is busy goes through like it goes
through different things but yeah you
know like after Christmas January
February typically is slow um because
people spend their money um you know
February 14th you know Valentine's Day
people come out you guys have the Super
Bowl this year here yeah we do um I'm
actually um um doing something for it
tomorrow I'm shooting I can't say what
it is but I I don't know if it's going
to air or if it's a commercial but it's
it's pretty exciting and um yeah it's
it's it's pretty cool but um but yeah
somehow we managed to to to do uh to do
really really well and uh I'm just so
thankful to the fans and people that
come out to to see the show and uh you
know people have a great time it's a
party it's it's craziness it's it has
every emotion it's an emotional roller
coaster but you got to come check it out
definitely you you'd enjoy it
yeah can't wait to yeah can can you help
me understand like when you walked in
here you said you're a little bit of a
mentalist was that real like is that I
was kind of [__] with you I going to
say like can you [__] explain to me
how they can look at somebody's face did
I sa you when I when you walked in I
think I forgot you said you were like oh
you got married at the White Chapel yeah
yeah yeah but but but then I'm CU I'm
like dude when somebody like looks at
somebody and they just like write down
the name of their dog and show it to
like what the [__] is that it's all
[__] okay there is no all you got to
say God take me undercover with you this
will be a show let's go undercover to
like you know tarot card readers people
that can read your palm and we'll go sit
there and I'll have a little camera and
I'll like completely expose it's all
cold reading it's all [__] like
somebody says hey it's listen it's magic
it's tricks it's Illusions it's all of
that stuff you know Houdini spent what
half of his life debunking these people
his mom yeah like 1926 he died but his
mom died and he lost his mom he super
upset about that and uh was he he he so
wanted to communicate with her and like
all the Seance people yeah the mediums
would be like oh your mom's talking to
me and and then he realized that they
were using the same tactics that he
would employ doing tricks so he exposed
them and then he got sued and he would
go to court and so his half of his life
that's what he did he battled these
people so when he died in 1926 on
Halloween he said to his wife beess I'm
going to give you a
word because people are going to claim
that they connected to me and contacted
me asked them what what I'm
telling telling you telling them to give
to tell you and so basically they held a
seance for 10 years it was a vigil it
was um in California on top of the I
think the ruselt hotel and um right
where my star is by the way which is
cool that they tied it together with
Houdini but uh they had a 10-year vigil
there Seance and eventually his uh wife
blew out the light and said that no one
was capable of making that connection
and the word that they had before he
died that he told his wife would be is
the word believe and in the word believe
in the center of that word is
lie so none of them um said hey we're
contacting you what's what is he saying
believe no one did that yeah about that
guy that would the great Randy James
Randy yeah I knew him I know James Randy
when I was 17 years old I had a cable
access show called
hotkicks uh back in the day in Brook
Haven New York I uh had him on and he
was the one who came up with me
confirming to be called uh Chris Angel
no [__] yeah my my real name is
Christopher Nicholas
sendos then I had Santos then I had
santis and then I was thinking about
angel he's like Angel that's a great
name for you you look nothing like an
angel and you have birds in your show
and and I I kept it and uh I've known
him uh for many many years he was always
very kind to me he passed um but uh but
he started a foundation that debunked or
proved that it that that what people
claimed to be psychic or Supernatural
that he couldn't reproduce or explain
how it worked and he did that when he
died the guy that started running his
foundation is a guy is a dear friend of
mine
banich um who um runs that foundation
and uh they have a million dollars for
anybody that can do anything that can't
be explained or reproduced and then I
jumped in I put a million dollars on a
line a couple of times to uh to offer to
like some of the Long Island psychic and
all these people just to and they just
run they just run yeah I mean you
remember watching that documentary with
me when he would just like go on The
Today Tonight Show or whatever it was
and these people would come out and he's
like okay why don't you do this and
you'll like put a box around it and then
they can't do it like I just it's just
I'm not feeling it today or it we're
going to move this pen with our mind and
he said okay and he would take like
little styrofoam and put it on there and
said okay move the pen and not with the
styrofoam because one of the techniques
is is that you blow on the table which
makes Peno in Reverse um or there's some
other technique so like you know you he
was on Johnny Carson and he had a guy
named orella on who I did a show with
and origel claimed that he could Bend
forks and silverware and all of these
different things and then when I was in
front of him I said on television I said
okay I'll give you a million dollars
Bend this Fork right now cuz I I bend
Forks all the time no show me and he
wouldn't do it and he claimed that it
was a tri if I do it now it's a trick
you know but what I did back then was
and I was just like so kind of exposed
that it was [__]
um I do want to push back though because
I feel like there have been some really
pretty credible
psychic things I'll give you an example
my dad went to see a
psychic um with at the time my stepmom
the psychic said your your first
wife um needs to be set
free because her ashes have not been
spread right like so the
psychic knew that my dad a had a first
wife B his first wife is dead and that
the the ashes were sitting in an earn on
uh a shelf in my sister's bedroom closet
because we just hadn't come up with with
an idea for for spreading these ashes
okay so um you ever buy uh a car and as
soon as you take it out on the road you
realize oh there's my car over there
there's my car over there you ever but
when you don't have that car you never
notice that so here's what
happens it's basically called cold
reading so you weren't there actually
listening to the chain of events and if
I guarantee you if you videotape that
and you listen into the playback um you
would see and I could point out exactly
the method of how they do it they they
talk about a lot of things people have
Expressions body
language they're engaged they might even
say something so if I'm talking General
generalizing about different things and
I see that you have an interest in
something I'm going to feed off of your
body language how you react your facial
expressions if you respond to to me and
I'm going to constantly go and go
further and further once I hit something
I'm going to start going more in that
direction and I'm going to start digging
and trying to see okay which path am I
going I'm changing paths constantly then
at the end of that process you're going
to leave there and the only thing you're
going to remember is what you want to
remember that's important to you that's
why Houdini had such a problem with
people taking advantage of people that
lost the loved one because people would
go to psychic and say I love this person
I miss him and people would take the
psychics would take these people these
vulnerable people their money and
essentially just give them false hope
and just read them and respond to
them based on the information that they
were gathering while they were talking
to that person it's called cold reading
and it's just you know I've hypnotized
you know you know what 150 people to
remove their clothes um I've I've done a
lot of these things I've exposed this
stuff it is you know the sad part about
it is is that we take this and it
doesn't become just entertainment or a
trick anymore we're taking this and
we're putting such a value on it and
we're putting a value on it because it
goes to our heart with somebody that we
love and this most intimate connection
that we have as humans and
now I'm exposing that it's [__] and
now you feel like oh my God this thing
that I thought it it's kind of like when
you find out Santa Claus as a kid it's
there's no Santa Claus I can assure you
if people had the ability to do that why
on 910 they did not predict
9911 why are they sitting there trying
to take $10 $20 $40 for a reading when
they can literally just predict what a
lottery would be I mean there's so many
reasons and so many facts but for me
being somebody who's been doing magic
since I was 6 years old and I'm not a
specialist in anything I'm a general
practitioner but I
know a bit about all the different
disciplines within the art um from my P
perspective I would love to see anyone
do
something for me couple people I have a
lot of respect for that we can't explain
it or reproduce it have you ever and we
put our we put our money on the line for
that have you ever been asked to uh be
on the show Tyler Henry the Hollywood
medium no they would never have me on
that show they would like I said the
Long Island psychic which was somebody
that yeah garnered a lot of you know I
offered we offered $2
million um yeah the these people it's
just they're basically doing a show but
they're claiming it's real that's where
my problem is if they went out there and
said hey we're going to do some mind
reading and blah blah blah but they
don't sit there and say like this is
real
um it crosses the line because he's
saying that he has an ability that no
one else has and he's going to make
money off of that ability and take
advantage of those vulnerable people
that lost to loved one and for me um
these charlatans have been
around throughout the course of history
you know because people capitalize and
take advantage of people it's all the
same [__] I promise you I would love
to do a show now and go in
undercover into the best
psychics and just expose them I mean
maybe that's something we need to do
steo I I I mean we'll have the quest of
just going out there and who's this guy
Tyler Henry Tyler Henry now I gotta be
fully transparent here I went on this
Tyler Henry show and I'm and it's a
there's cameras they're filming to put
it on TV and I don't want to be a chump
so I'm like going into it with like the
most
skepticism and uh but how are you GNA
have skepticism if you don't know
methods and techniques that people like
myself have been doing since I was 6
years old like how do you you it's like
you're going to fight I saw you fight uh
was it Holly you wrestled Holly oh yeah
Hol how have a chance against somebody
that's you have no chance dude no chance
whatsoever Frank mir's coming here he's
going to be part of the panel you have
like no chance so my point is if I sat
with you and we watched that I could say
look at that there's something called
pre-show there's something that they do
before they start rolling the cameras
they start going in asking people to do
questioner or hey you know what hey we
want to ask you some questions but just
write them down so you remember what
we're talking about you don't even give
it to us you hold on to put it in your
pocket right it's all of this [__]
that sets up the scene trust me I I've
done all this stuff on you know what a
100 plus episodes of mind freak then on
my show believe that I did on another
Network and this is the stuff that I
employ I do all of this stuff um to
create the illusion but people know I'm
an Entertainer um they know that it's
that I'm not not trying to pass it off
as something legitimate so in order for
you to be a skeptic you really have to
be educated all right in in in in that
art because it is an art I uh I I I
can't push back on that well it's just
hard to like H like when they're like
pick a number between one and a thousand
and then they're
like 467 yeah but but what happened
before that where did you what did you
what did you write it down on did you
write down
467 right right right see what you're
doing you're doing exactly what I said
happened when they went to that uh
psychic you're
choosing moments that stick out to you
like holy [__] and you're forgetting
about all the other moments that had to
lead to that moment that might look
innocent that you might not even realize
something's going on right yeah so
that's that's the thing so if we pulled
up like a shorts clip on YouTube of a
Mentalist on the street you can be like
this is what he just did well you can't
believe anything that you see on TV
because there's so much [__] that
happens I I I used to get accused of
[__] like you know on mind freak like oh
CGI no I did things practical but you
know I would get accused of all the then
you watch now what they're putting out
there and it's like it's so apparent
like there's not even an attempt to try
to you know make it look legit so like
the movie that The Men Who Stare at
Goats when the government was hiring
people to like hone in on [__] for
the government that's my friend uh
banich who I mentioned to you early and
the reason why Randy picked him to run
his organization um when he passed on
was because banich fooled
scientists um he legitimately was
studied him and his friend was studied
because of the things that they were
able to bend metal and move objects that
were complete
you know surrounded in in glass and he
was able to move it and do things like
light you know just just things that he
did it was called the Alpha Project I
believe it was called and uh and then he
exposed that he was just a magician but
he was able to fool scientists the
easiest people to fool are the people
that are the most educated that think
they're an authority on a subject the
hardest people to fool are like
people that are like kids because I'll
be like hey and they be like what's in
this
hand they don't they don't they're not
conditioned when somebody is conditioned
with a way to
think those people are easy to misdirect
when somebody is uh just basically like
a
free uh free thinker and doesn't think
in a specific pattern they're more
difficult h that makes sense you know
magic is psychology like if I'm talking
to you right now and I and I go like
this you're going to look at my hand you
just did right so that's the those are
the things that I'm saying it's all
about controlling allowing somebody to
feel like they're in control but in
reality I'm the one who's in control of
everything MH and you can do that in so
many
ways wow it's fantastic dude that's some
juice see [__] um okay there's one more
thing that I think of there was uh and
and and it goes to the near-death
experience phenomena again this
uh a doctor a scientist and this is like
uh I saw it in some like
pretty I don't know some form and a
patient
like died was in a coma or or whatever
um the doctor was uh in like the
cafeteria at the hospital or something
spilled tomato like spaghetti sauce like
on his shirt and and he was like oh man
you know what a rookie move and like
like uh buttoned up his lab coat and
then like went back and uh and then like
the the patient like comes out of the
coma or whatever and was like oh you
know yeah you spilled he like it was
covered they couldn't see it I've seen
that um okay so let me make a very clear
distinction the distinction is this we
were talking about psychics
mentalists you know that claim that they
have the supernatural
power I have
faith I believe in God okay I can't
comment on what happens if somebody is
clinically dead
because that's not magic that's
something that you know is completely in
a different world literally so for me I
have even though I'm a huge skeptic when
it comes to man I have a tremendous
faith when it comes to God so it's a
distinction so I I can't sit here and
say that I'm fascinated by that so
you're okay with the spaghetti stained
story 100% yes you know why because
you're talking
about somebody who is talking about they
were clinically dead they knew something
that happened when they weren't even in
that room right or was supposed to were
no one bear witness to it they're you
know under you know um they're knocked
out and they wake up and they know this
stuff so like listen in situations like
that I I you know unless I'm there and
I'm in the operating room and I know
that that person I I can't sit there and
comment I just know what these people do
these charlatans the people that scam
people you know it's like three card
Monty I know the technique of that it's
been around forever people are going to
continuously do that and do that and do
that but it's the same [__] this stuff
here is the same stuff like that's
banich banich is a guy that comes across
like you think the [__] he's doing is
real right the [__] that I do looks like
it's real but we don't sit there and say
it's real M you know cuz that's that's
crossing the line we're we're doing
tricks love that you know and it's also
significant that this guy who had the
Spaghetti Stain was like a super
legitimate Doctor Who had nothing to
gain by by making he was there's many
stories like that yeah I saw one with a
woman a similar situation the guy was
like she was out and she knew things
that were happening when she died in
that room that it was impossible for her
to know because she didn't have any
family members there it's you know
doctors and nurses and she woke up and
then when she recovered she was like oh
blah blah blah and he was like how did
you know it's impossible for you to know
so I I that's what I'm saying I that's
that's a different that's a different
love world I'm so glad that that cleared
that up because yeah now for every
painting there's a Creator all right let
me ask you this
um
reincarnation what about like the the
stories of little kids who are are uh
you know they're remembering past lives
where like they're looking at photos
recognizing people naming them by name
oh that was my car in the photo I feel
like and and think well there's another
one that maybe Isaac can look up there I
saw like a [__] 16mon old baby just
playing like Bach on the piano it's like
how what is that you know um I I
personally don't believe in
reincarnation know it goes against kind
of my faith but um like this look at
this this it's incredible I mean what is
that a
prodigy you ever see the kids that can
paint insanely oh yeah online there Ian
do you think maybe this was Mozart
coming back into it like no I just I
just think I just think this is a
prodigy this is somebody that just like
has you know a lot of people go through
life and they never find their passion
what they're good at because they're so
consumed with what they have to do to
pay the bills and they never get that
opportunity to explore you know um
obviously this is something that's
insanely natural for this kid so you
know there's there's so many things that
are you we can't know everything yeah
and the problem is man wants to know
everything it's
impossible like we could sit here and
debate forever you know how did Earth
form you know how you know all of these
different things and what It ultimately
comes down to is what you believe in
what your faith is right I mean that's
that's the thing mhm or like the that
can paint you know that one elephant
that can paint like it's like happy or
sad [__] it's wild [__] yeah I mean
there just stuff that we're never going
to know I dude I I love it man I love it
and and when when you say the the belief
in reincarnation goes against your faith
like end of yeah no and but you know
what we live in an amazing country that
people can believe whatever they wish
and you got to respect them for what
they believe yeah you know and and I do
I don't I don't put what I believe on
anyone you know I I don't I I it's my
personal belief it's what I think and
you know this country was founded on
that you know and it's it's like whether
you're liberal or you're a conservative
at the end of the day you look at
President Reagan and tip O'Neal two
different perspectives but they were
still friends and at the end of the day
they went out and had drinks together
that's what we need today doesn't matter
what you believe or what we could still
like have love and friendship we don't
have to hate each other because you
believe this way and I believe that way
why why why has why has this country
evolved and transformed into that it's
really unfortunate it doesn't have to be
that way yeah okay last question yeah
cryptocurrency where are you at on
that why why would you I'll tell you
I'll tell you a quick story about this
oh
no I didn't lose any money and I didn't
make any
money but uh but a friend of mine Jean
Simmons okay came here he spent two days
with me we're just hanging out we're
talking and and he's like Chris you got
to get into crypto got I've made all
this money he showed me his phone and it
was
considerable and uh he's like you got to
get into this so I'm
like okay so I call up I talk to uh my
manager who who's a very smart guys
Harvard graduated with a law degree and
stopped practicing law now they
represent you know Justin Timberlake
Martin cresy they produced the Irishman
and mle crew the dirt Dave baram is his
name great
guy he's like ah you know I know I know
and so I just I I just didn't I don't I
invest in myself because I trust myself
and if I fail then okay but I don't when
I don't know something like during covid
I threw some money into some stocks
because I knew what was going to happen
not knew it like TR or like it was more
call it more psychic it was more
psychic so like stuff like that when I
know a business I know an art form or
something like that that that that's
makes me more comfortable but to make a
long story
short the whole thing collapsed and
thank God I didn't get into it because
Gan was like he gave me phone numbers to
call people and I never did it I
explored it a little bit but never got
into it I don't know what the outcome
was for him I'm hoping that he got his
money out before it collapsed but yeah
no it's it's um you know it's crazy it
do you have money in in I I don't but I
I I got a buddy who anymore
or thinking about getting into it you
know what I did like when the N when the
nft thing was was popping off like uh I
sold one nft but made it like did the
thing sold it like I think it was like
um you know 1 e or or like
1.01 e which at the time was like 3,000
bucks and in order to do that I set up a
whole thing I came up with the password
which was a whole series of words wrote
it down on a cardboard box so that it
wouldn't be like you know like and and
the cardboard boxes in the closet my
editor sounds like a magic trick yeah my
editor like like reorganized the closet
because we got all the production [__]
in there and he threw away the cardboard
box can't get you three grand now yeah
and and now like the three grand one e
at this point is like 2, 2500 well how
do you get your money out because there
was there was no but there was a
documentary did you see that documentary
about like the credit card scheme that
you could just use this credit card to
get your crypto money out and then it
was a scheme they they stole like tens
of millions of dollars it's on I think
it's on Netflix what was that I I forgot
what it was called but I just watched it
like a week ago uh is yeah like crypto
boys or something maybe yeah it was it
was these young guys that that that
started a scam yeah oh look at he's good
bitcon yeah that's it oh bitcon did you
see that I did you got to watch that
watch that yeah the guys the dude that
scamed people they're wrong
dude got no jail time wow don't wor I'm
gonna watch it yeah yeah I I love a good
documentary you like UFC fights do you
go to those well you can say I like it I
train I train for uh I have a purple
belt no [__] yeah and I I train I have a
gym at my house I train like four or
five days a week two to four hours a day
with a guy named Frank Mir who's my
professor two time UFC heavyweight
champion and then uh uh Jake Ellenberger
who's a UFC veteran he's my training
partner and then I have like Anthony
Pettis and so I I'm really into it I
train train uh pretty hardcore in like
MMA like so it's ground Jiu-Jitsu
wrestling you know and then standup
boxing um Muay Thai karate and then you
know grappling and that's how you stay
in shape for your shows yeah and and I I
do a little workout you know the show is
very physically demanding and um so I I
I just I love my passion is um is MMA
it's like what I totally just love doing
I go in there I have this nice little
gym in there and everybody just comes
and visits and Frank's always there and
then I just come and I train with
different people and I pick up I have
Jake Shields coming in and I'm he's
really good uh against the cage and just
trying to pick up some moves and stuff
like I love that stuff you would love
getting into some grappling too I know
you'd be good at it anytime you want to
come over and
train yeah well you're gonna see Frank
Mir so you come over and Jake Ellenberg
is going to be here too I love it
they're awesome they're uh really really
talented but I I've been doing it and uh
really hardcore uh like I say you know
four or five days two to four hours a
day just [__] you know and Frank's a big
dude he's two he was he's 275 280 now so
rolling with him is wow is not easy um
let me ask you this
uh our podcast that we're going to
record for you mhm um when do you think
that's gonna that's a good question
because because because what I was gonna
say is let's direct everybody who's
watching yeah years oh well maybe we can
put that when is this coming out this
will be uh two weeks from this Thursday
okay well definitely Jeremy Corbell
Sebastian Bach Chris Angel yeah yeah yep
two weeks from this Thursday so do me a
favor and then invite me and I'll collab
with you so that I don't know that
that's a thing thing on YouTube oh you
don't put it on Instagram on Instagram
we no on Instagram oh yeah we can do a
promo we'll get some clips cut and we'll
make you a collaborator yeah and then
and then I'll share and then if you
could do the same thing for me but
definitely uh I don't know because are
we still rolling or are we done no we're
still rolling we're I'll tell you what
we we like uh we'll leave it like this
okay so now I'm gonna go record your
podcast yeah so we have uh Frank Mir on
the panel we have Mike Hammer really
funny guy magic comedy guy and then we
have uh Jake ellenburger so and then we
have our guest Mr steo so we're going to
talk a lot and I'm going to get I'm
telling you right now I'm not going to
hold back I'm going to get deep because
I'm going to talk about the [__] you
talked about
me yeah he's playing nice guy on on
here the three of you against me is this
open eject yeah dude thank you so much
for having me man I enjoyed the hon yeah
I enjoy of
that another great episode and
198 making us dangerously close to
episode 200 what is it going to be well
spoiler alerts live in my new Reddit
Forum which is
rstor and um as I said in the intro been
having a little bit of a struggle for
the last couple months what happened was
uh you know I went on this
insane promo tour to promote my bucket
list special which uh I'm almost ready
to release on DVD the window for uh
getting it online is over um if you
didn't get to see it you're going to
have to either wait for the DVD or wait
I I don't know but uh enough with that
um while I was doing that promo run I
did like 50 podcasts and I just got
burned out you know I got burned out
ended up uh just being burned out and
and screwing up interviews there was
this one show that said sto's podcast
appearances are a mess and that hurt
because I agreed with it you know um got
I just got like I felt like the internet
kind of turned on me I mean I'm sure
that that's not the total picture but uh
man this this one interview I did with
uh Santino like um all I heard saw was
oof the comment section on this one and
to know that there's like Mass
like Mass scale like hate negative
comments like dude it bums me out man it
bums me out dude so I kind of just like
uh fought through my podcast and and and
just try to hang like hide out at the my
Ranch but like I said I'm I'm I'm
bouncing back from that dude I'm letting
all of that make me a better person if
if I can you know what I mean and um and
uh I'm really excited about the the
Reddit form because I can put whatever I
want in there like the filthiest stuff
there's no Community guidelines not safe
for work and I can give it to you guys
completely for free so uh get on over
there the pinned comment is a is a dope
one and uh yeah man what can I say I
love you you're my street team thank you
for sticking around to the end and uh
love light and positivity man that's
what it's all about thank you